صيف عام
2022 يشكل تاريخا فارقا في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ليس
ميدانيا التطور تمثل بالتوقيع على ما سمي
اتفاق البحر الاسود او اتفاقيه اسطنبول
اهميتها تكمن في انها سمحت باعاده تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه والتقليل من حده ازمه
الغذاء
العالميه كما اتاحت لروسيا تصدير منتجات
زراعيه
واسمده رغم العقوبات عليها علقت روسيا
العمل بالاتفاقيه في شتاء العام نفسه
تذرعت انذاك باستهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود في سيفاستوبول وبعد تدخل دبلوماسي
تركي استؤنف الاتفاق وبعد اقل من عام
انسحبت موسكو منه بشكل كلي في مقابل ذلك
وتحت وطاه ازمه غذاء عالميه بدات تتجدد
قررت اوكرانيا اعتماد مسارات بديله لتصدير
حبوبها باعتماد ميناء اديسا وموانئ على
نهر
الدنوب تقول روسيا ان الامم المتحده
والغرب تجاهلا شرطا مهما في صفقه الحبوب
وهو استئناف تصدير الامونيا الروسيه عبر
انبوب تولياتي اوديسا والذي فجر داخل
الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وايضا تعاني روسيا تقطع تصدير
منتجاتها الزراعيه بشكل سالث حسب ما تقول
وتتهم روسيا الامم المتحده بالتغاضي عما
تصفها بالهجمات الارهابيه والاعمال
التخريبيه
الاوكرانيه وتعتبر موسكو ان الامم المتحده
فشلت في تطبيق احد بنود الاتفاق الذي ينص
على اعاده ادماج المصرف الزراعي الروسي
بنظام سويفت للتعاملات المصرفيه الخاصه
باتفاق الحبوب
اوكرانيا عدت حينها انسحاب روسيا من
الاتفاقيه بانها خطه مسبقه تهدف من خلالها
موسكو الى حصار الموانئ والهيمنه على
البحر الاسود ثم احتكار سوق الحبوب
العالمي بالهيمنه على اسواق التصدير
الاوكرانيه قصرا ومنذ الانسحاب الروسي
نشطت اكثر من دوله على الصعيد الدبلوماسي
لايجاد حلول تفاديا لازمه غذاء جديده
فكانت مبادره قطريه تركيه تنص على ان تغطي
الدوحه ثمن كميات كبيره من القمح تصل الى
مليون طن ترسل الى البلدان الاكثر حاجه
بالتزامن مع محاوله تركيا احياء اتفاق
اسطنبول لتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه لكن كما يبدو فان موسكو لا ترى
تعارضا بين استئناف مبادره الحبوب والعمل
بالمبادره القطر
فبينما كان يؤمل ان يعلن الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان استعاده الاتفاق في
اجتماعه مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
في سوتشي فقد افضل الاجتماعه الى مزيد من
التشاور كما يبدو من كلمتي بوتين واردوغان